you see what china just did with banning
lgbt groups
wechat one of their largest you know
social platforms banned a bunch of lgbt
accounts
so you can see what what power does in
the united states just so happens the
left communist faction
uh and the marxists have a lot of
institutional authority and and
and people to understand this that it
there there is a massive infiltration of
marxism
in this government what they need to
understand about critical theory and
marxism is it's the idea of the
oppressed and the oppressor right
that is that the system is inherently uh
you know bad and evil it must be torn
down
um right so so it's not it's not about
like stalin's sneaking into the
government
it's about quite literally there are
people in the government the military's
doing it the the the uh
what do we just have was it lockheed
where were there like you know white
people got to recognize them yeah
yeah yeah so at our military-industrial
complex our government our police forces
our army
are all embracing marxist theory they
might not know that but it literally is
marxist what's concerning is if it's a
presser and a press
and i'm the oppressed then i overturn
the oppressor then what does that leave
it leaves me to become the oppressor
it doesn't it's not meaningless it's
just power structures
it is it is it's an ideology that is
basically like um how can i describe it
it's like when you when you when you
look
at an atomic structure and you find the
one
frail atom that when you flick the whole
thing crumbles sounds like fluorine
well it starts it's not floating this
was the electrostatic or electro
elastic i mean this was known as
hydrofluoric acid
i mean what you're talking about is the
same as what used to be called critical
legal theory which became
actually pretty ascended you know at
harvard law school yeah um a couple
decades ago but it's but it's the same
it's the same
exact idea yeah yeah they they want to
find a way to demonize a villain
create an other it's very demagogic i
suppose
and it works so what is it the but it's
really really quite smart because what
they'll do is they'll say
you're a racist and quite literally you
have like james lindsay being like
discriminating him on the basis of race
is wrong and they go racist
it's like okay so yeah that's what it is
that's what they believe
if this theory is oppressor and
oppressed and the oppressor
the powerful are press oppressive by
nature is that part of this theory
no no no no so uh initially with marks
you have like the the the class
right the bourgeoisie the proletariat
the working class the elites the
political class etc
then you get critical race theory where
they're like white people
critical critical replace the
bourgeoisie with white people basically
right theory so now with critical race
theory you have oppressed oppressors and
the white people are the
oppressors and the people of color are
the oppressed
and is the theory that if you were to
remove white people from the equation
that there would no longer be an
oppressor
uh that white people need to recognize
their privilege and give up their power
this is very disturbing it's meaningless
because you can't take your skin color
off
right yeah so the idea ultimately is
that you will always be an oppressor no
matter what
all of which of course is precisely why
we have certain laws that just
just explicitly outlaw this kind of
thing um and it's and it's and it's
fascinating uh it's fascinating to watch
some of these
um you know state and local governments
and corporations attempt to
um you know implement laws um that are
just they're so
flatly uh illegal and contrary to like
the civil rights
laws you know that were passed in the
1960s but you know and they think that
they can just
get away with it and they will unless
they're challenged critical race
theorists
hated civil rights of course one of the
core tenets of critical race theory is
critique of liberalism
they felt that the the the liberal
liberalism was a little ill
right yeah they thought that the
democrats and and desegregation and
civil rights was actually de-powering
their community they hated it they were
very critical of the democrats
first of all you had the democrats that
were pro-segregation and then also the
democrats started to say okay well maybe
we'll we'll get behind these bills for a
variety of reasons
and there was there was a letter
circulated during the ferguson riots
among activists that argued segregation
was a plot by white democrats
to force black people to exist
underneath the
economics of the white system this
desegregation yeah right so so
what uh what these activists were saying
when their this letter
before the end of segregation when
everything was separated
they said black people had their own
wealth their own neighborhoods their own
communities
their own churches they have their own
wall street along comes the democrats
and say hey we should end segregation
it's wrong and as soon as that happened
you have these two systems where yes you
have a lot of very wealthy white people
but the black community was building
up their wealth now they're forced to
exist at a lower economic standard
to the white people that what they were
basically arguing was
when you had segregation a black person
would run their own restaurant
with the end of segregation the black
person would go work for the white man's
restaurant
now i think that's a bit silly you could
still have your own restaurant you can
still have your own communities
and i think it's an overtly racist
ideology and the end of segregation was
a very very good thing but these
activists genuinely believe
that we need that they believe
segregation was
uh some it's something they want i'll
put it that way when they hate martin
luther king
they but they but they know that he's
popular among liberals and the liberals
are the ones they can exploit
so they say things like yay dr king and
i always say this to
my to my woke friends martin luther king
jr
he uh dr king he said i have a dream
that one day my four little children
will be judged
not by the color of their skin but by
the content of their character
how are you fulfilling dr king's dream
exactly
and they say yeah you don't even know
what he was about
okay i guess i don't know he said those
things so do you think that allowing
schools to implement ra
race-based discrimination is helping dr
king's dream or hurting it
wow now hold on path is long let's find
out you're getting a lot of leftists who
have no problem criticizing him
because it's becoming so prominent and
prevalent that they're now
much more free to do so so when we we
talked about this book that's being
taught in school it's called not my idea
it's a children's book where a little
white girl is exposed to the truth by
her teachers about
race and she's angry with her mom who
lied to her and she screams i'm tired of
you
lying to me mom tell me the truth i see
race
and the mom says oh no then there's a
whiteness contract with a white hand
reaching out in a devil's tail
yeah white white people are the devil
they say you got to see this portion
they're teaching this to children in
dozens of schools but
in many of these schools once they get
to that portion where it shows the white
person as the devil they stop
they don't show it and they say you can
read the rest of the book on your own
you know why
it's the insidious nature if they come
out right now
and tell children white people are the
devil their parents will flip
out but if they give them the beginning
of the book
see police brutality is wrong they were
lying to you these liberals might be
like huh okay
they have to do it slowly slowly it's
insidious these liberals are easy to
exploit because they look at something
and they say that's unfair
they've got to do it slowly once enough
liberals support this book
then they'll turn the last page and say
white people are the devil and then
these people go
oh yeah well i think these look these
parents
look these parents these moms are
starting to stand up in these school
board meetings
which i think is a very good thing i
think when i was driving down here i
went through ludon
county right right nearby which loudon
which which is
of course where uh you know they wanted
to shut down debate and then it dragged
out
uh the sheriff's deputies dragged out
the parents who wanted to actually
finish the period of debate
um that was called for right um but you
know look
the the the the way that these things
are gonna turn around is is that people
you know people who love this country
and you know
moms at a certain point will protect
their kids but these folks are going to
start running for the school board and
they're going to start running for local
offices and you know i mean good people
have to
good people have to get in politics and
run for um office because that's i mean
like that's where the real power is
that's where real change comes from is
where you can actually take your pin and
you can sign you know a piece of
legislation
and um you know i i think that's
starting to happen it certainly feels
like it's starting to happen
i'm starting to think that this 100 year
experiment of public school systems is
is showing its cracks as flaws and the
dangers of putting your kids in a
foreign
environment and letting just letting
letting things happen to them
strangers can tell your kids so many bad
teachers
just as awesome terrible terrible old
angry
evil worthless useless i'm going to say
the worst stuff no they're probably fine
people but just not
not able to handle young a group of 30
kids at a time it was terrible
yeah i mean it's just it's just i mean
they're states like you know i suppose
new york and california come to mind
where i mean the public education you
know the public school system seems to
be
it seems to be disastrous and and it's
hard to know what what to do i mean i
think the solution is probably
multifaceted i mean it involves some
degree of school choice it involves some
degree of
um you know getting the funds actually
where they need to be
to make sure that you can reduce class
sizes and you know get good teachers in
there but but yeah i mean
we we we can't we cannot have um a
system in this country
um where you know and i'm very fortunate
that my kids you know go to amazing um
an amazing
private school but you cannot have a
system where um you know a certain
number of elite kids you know
um have teachers who are kindergarten
teachers with phds and they have an
amazing experience and then you have
you know the masses of people whose kids
are not only
in physical danger um but they're being
indoctrinated like this
voucher program yeah look i'm a i'm a
i'm a huge believer in in uh you know
choice and competition
and so you know school choice and
voucher programs uh in competition
um you know generally speaking seem to
me to be very good ideas
very good ideas um i i think you know
the health care system also needs you
know more competition
um and whatnot i think i think the trick
becomes exactly how to implement
these things um yeah you know so that so
it's actually effective uh but
what but but what we have right now in
these big blue states and these
these these these cities is not it's
just not tenable so something else
that's
trash but well it's just i mean the
cities themselves man i'm just so
i'm anti-city right now it's not a good
time to be in a big city
we're we're outside in the front today
with uh andy
um andy is a guy who's gonna be he's
gonna be running all the wreck area
stuff he's gonna be running the the
grind bar
and we're gonna be sitting with events
and stuff so he's we're standing in the
front and we're trying to plan out like
so where do we build the mega ramp
like where do we put the the giant
launch for the skate park
and it's not about look i understand not
everybody can you know go and buy
materials for a skate park
but you have space you can walk outside
with your friends and just look at the
grass and say what can we do here
what activity should we have in these
cities it's brutal man you live in a
cubicle
yeah your kids are in a crammed school
environment she doesn't even know their
name
teacher's like who is this you're in my
class um
miss wilson i've been in your class all
year huh i can't even tell i got too
many kids
you know well i don't want to live in
that it's a different it's awful
different type of versatility
no and i think that could look i think
that you're going to have uh
people start to look people who want to
live a certain way and believe in
certain things are going to start
self-selecting out out of the cities
um and to be you know in places that
seem safer
and in which you know they're not
attacked for having a maga hat on
um and you know i think that you know
and obviously with uh
with covid and the way folks have gotten
more used to working remotely i think
it's going to accelerate that trend and
that
and that and that could lead to further
you know that could lead to further
division in the country because you know
we're
i think we're going to have people sort
of segregating themselves away from
each other um because there's just too
much volatility
right now yeah you know we're gonna go
tomorrow see a movie hang out have some
candy and popcorn
then we're gonna just relax and enjoy a
saturday we've been filming it we make a
vlog out of it we're gonna start ramping
up doing daily vlogs and everything but
the point is
there's got to be something else to kind
of clear your mind oh yeah help you
focus on other things i do music because
i want to scream when i want to
when i want to exert my rage on someone
i just got to turn it into song i got to
scream with my body's
full vigor and it's it's a bit of
your vocal cords yeah but it's good for
my mind playing the drums but it doesn't
hurt other people because like
taking it out on someone else is
terrible you can't scream in a city
though
they do it online and they're text and
it doesn't yeah they can kind of tell
when they're reading on their
in their text but if you're if you live
in a city so i it's hard i lived in the
city
i lived in brooklyn can't have drums
can't play guitar
you can play guitar but it's like within
certain hours because like you hear the
pounding on the floor then unless you're
really good your neighbors are going to
complain yeah they're going to complain
no matter what but don't
always complain if you're really good i
lived i lived in an apartment where
someone in the building worked a
graveyard shift and they're always like
it's like 5 p.m and they're like excuse
me i i understand but look man i got to
sleep
and we're like we'll do our best because
we're trying to be nice it's brutal
i i listened to harker history and and
you know listen to the stories about how
um alexander uh the great's mom was you
know
like super difficult sometimes and then
after after he died from partying too
hard there was like literally like
40 years of um warfare among his
generals to try to sort things out which
you know
which makes you feel like you know it
could be worse i heard that he was
poisoned
i heard that theory oh well for sure
that's a major
uh theory uh uh you know i don't i don't
think anybody
knows for sure i would be surprised if
he wasn't at this point
he had look he he had he had it he had
put together
the world you know the largest empire
that the world had seen at that point
um and so you know so there was a lot of
folks with a lot of
you know motivations um to do such thing
uh look
clearly he seemed to um uh
you know like to like to have a good
time as well um you know and so
who knows for sure um with respect to
you know the amount of alcohol that
you know he was uh you know supposed to
consume um but but
no they're like i i would say that the i
would say that the consensus among
serious historians is that yes he was he
was assassinated he had
led all his generals across you know
persia and was conquering the world and
they were like okay we did it well no
they yeah and we go home now yeah
yeah they got basically like halfway
like through india and they're kind of
looking around at like the himalayan
mountains in the snow and they're like
okay like i mean like seriously like
what what what's
like what's the point like here my
assumption was he was like we're gonna
go forever and they were like no we're
gonna we have to stop him
he's gone too yeah well he's one of the
most i mean he's one of those
fascinating personalities
in history and he had insatia you know
he had an insatiable appetite to conquer
everything he was he was
you know tutored from a young age by
what was it aristotle uh you know his
his mother his father was one of those
powerful figures of his age that handed
him like a ferrari of of an army
that was tailor-made to take to take
over persia
uh essentially and his mother is one of
the most um you know sort of
uh powerful fascinating manipulative
uh you know female characters in in in
the ancient period
for sure um and so yeah the alexander
great story is a good one
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
p.m where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you